Hey everyone! Welcome to the fifth and final installment on our elasticity series. We are looking at income and cross price elasticity. We're both of those are about and we're going to look at three examples to conclude our series. Let's go ahead and jump into it.
Our first one that we went to look at is the income elasticity. This measures the percentage change in quantity demand over the percentage change in income. So as our income increase we would expect either to consume more of a good or less of a good--it really depends on the category of the income elasticity. Let's start with the first, normal goods. These are goods that, normally speaking, whenever our income increase we have an increase in our quantity demand. Likewise, whenever our income decreases we have a decrease in our quantity demand. Let's think about airplane rides. With airplane rides as our income increases we want to travel more. Which means we will be consuming more airplane rides. Now unlike the conventional coach or main cabin you do have the first class.
These are going to be luxury goods. Tthese are going to have a very large income elasticity. Things that are far greater than the number one or something around there, which is typically what we see with our income elasticity.
Now, what about the third type?
We also have inferior goods. These are goods for which whenever your income decreases your quantity demand increases. We can also say whenever your income increases for these good your quantity demanded decreases. If we looked at a bus ride compared to a plane ride, buses were going to tend to be cheaper. They're going to tend to be very much slower than a plane ride, and it's going to take--maybe it's just doesn't not all that great of an experience. So these tend to be more of an inferior good compared to what we have with plane rides. These,
uhh, the elasticity of demand for a bus ride is going to be negative. This is a time you do not take the absolute value of the item that you're looking at. This is going to be a negative income elasticity.
Okay let's move on to our cross price elasticity. In this case were looking at two goods. Their percentage change in quantity demand of good one for the percentage change in the price of good two. So how do, how does the price of the second good affect the quantity of the first good? Let's start with complement goods. Complement goods show that as the price of the second good increases the quantity demand for good one is going to decreas. Let's go back to our plane example. Now, we're going to have air travel with hotel stays. As we begin to travel more we need to stay in hotels more. So what happens if all of a sudden, let's say air travel, the price of air travel increases what can we expect to happen to hotel stays? We should expect those fall. Alright, we should expect hotel stays to fall. Likewise if hotel prices increase per night stay we might see a decrease in the amount of air travel that's taking place.
Alright complement goods are going to be a negative cross price elasticity.
A substitute good is going to be a positive cross price elasticity. Here as the price of the second good increases quantity demand for good one increases. Look we have Air Taco and we have Taco Air. We can see Air Taco is a little bit beefier than Taco Air. So maybe they decide that they're going to lower the price of their goods. What's going to happen Taco Air quantity demand? It's gets going to rise.
So what we see is the price and quantity demand always move in the same direction
for substitute goods. That is there's a positive relationship between the price of good two and the quantity demand of good one.
Lastly, we have our unrelated goods. If the price of one good increases it has no effect whatsoever on the quantity demand of the other good. If the price of airplane tickets increases the quantity demand of clothing will not change their not related.
Let's finish up but looking at three examples here we're going to be using airplane travel and hotel stays. We have average income equal to $60,000 nightly hotel rates equal to $200 flights are $200 hotel bookings we have that set at 150 and then our total revenue the price of the hotel times the bookings is going to give us $30,000. Scenario 1.
Let's allow our income to increase by 10%, so this goes to $66,000. This causes more people to want to stay at a hotel they're travelling. So our hotel bookings increased to 162 and then our income elasticity--you can see our formula--here comes down to 0.81--that's positive. That lets us know that our hotels are going to be a normal good as our income increases we are going to increase our quantity demand of hotel stays. Further we get total revenue of $32,400, but this is good business for the hotel.
Scenario 2.
Flights increased by 30%. So the flight price is going to go from two hundred dollars to $260. This negatively affects hotel bookings. We go from 150 down to 114. So we should be thinking is this a substitute good or a complement good? Well we can clearly see as the price of one increases the quantity demand of the other decreases making it a substitute good. Let's see the cross price elasticity we have - 1.33. Again here we don't take the absolute value because we need to know is it a complement good or is it a substitute good. In this case it is a complement good because of that negative cross price elasticity.
Lastly we get total revenue $22,000 and 800, so in this case.
our total revenue really takes a hit by having those flight prices increased.  Last scenario.
Here we're going to have hotel rates fall by 20%.  So the nightly rate goes from $200 to $160. The law of demand says that is going to increase the quantity of bookings. Quantity of boookings goes from 150 to 180. This gives us a price elasticity of demand of -0.73. Here if you want to take the absolute value you can, that's fine. And you can see that we are going to be inelastic.
Our, this, this change in the hotel rate puts us at price inelastic. So we're beyond that unit elastic, where we maximize our total revenue and this might be a problem for the hotel because now they're not earning nearly as much as they used to earn at a price of $200. So the hotel might want to reevaluate their hotel rates and have them increased, so that way they can move back to maximizing their total revenue. Alright that is it for this series. I hope you have enjoyed it and we'll catch you in our next one.